Some of you guys don't know this about me,
but I'm fluent in Spanish, obviously English,
and now even whale!
We’ve long known that whales talk to each
other.
They relay messages to one another through
acoustic signals that come in the form of
clicks, whistles, and calls.
And the variations of these communicate different
messages - much like in human language we
use different words to make up sentences.
But, new research shows that some whale talk
may be even more complex than we originally
thought.
First off, whales exhibit vocal learning-
something found in only a small number of
species like
birds, bats, elephants, dolphins, and some
primates . Nope, sorry.
Your dog doesn’t fall in this category.
While dogs may bark to communicate, the reason
this is not considered vocal learning is because
dogs cannot manipulate their bark sounds or
learn new barks via imitation and modification.
But whales can.
They can learn and replicate new sounds they
encounter from other whales... basically,
whales can learn new words.
This ability to manipulate sound and learn
from others has actually made whale language
differ in different parts of the world . Like
regional dialects . The dialects are made
up of codas, which are specific sets of clicks
with varying pauses in between- that communicate
messages.
And these codas vary based on where the whales
are from and who they hang out with - which
researchers suggest marks cultural acquisition
. These codas seem to be passed down in communities
and altogether make up a specific form of
language.
In a recent study published in Royal Society
Open Science, researchers recorded the vocalizations
of nine different Caribbean sperm whale groups
over the course of six years . By analyzing
thousandsof coda recordings, the researchers
identified 21 unique codas.
One of these - the 1+1+3 coda - was produced
in exactly the same way by all nine groups
in the Caribbean.
But, this is not the case for other sperm
whales.
Sperm whales outside of the Caribbean produce
different codas.
So, the researchers suggest that this 1+1+3
coda acts as a regional dialect.
Orcas, are another whale species with similarly
rich vocalizations.
As reported in an article published in Animal
Behavior, when researchers studied four different
populations of orcas across the North Pacific
Ocean, they found that each community within
a specific geographic region produced a set
of matched vocalizations.
But, these sets were slightly different from
one another.
Though they had the same general structure,
the variations in how these sets were produced
could differentiate whales from different
families and regions.
If we’re talking people terms - this would
be close to what we consider an accent.
Similar to how humans can sort of tell if
a person is from the U.K. versus the US when
they both speak English.
And one study even found that orcas can learn
to speak dophin!
In a study published in the Journal of Acoustical
America, when ten orcas in captivity were
split up to be housed either with other orcas
or with bottlenose dolphins, researchers noted
that the three whales that were with dolphins
began to vocalize using more whistles and
clicks, just like their new friends.
But the seven other whales who were housed
with their same kind did not.
That they can pick out and imitate other cetaceans’
patterns is incredible!
But we’re just beginning to understand the
complexity of whales’ vocal learning, and
a lot of our current knowledge on dialects
and accents relies on recent studies with
sperm whales and orcas.
So more research is needed to really get how
and what these guys are saying.
But if you wanna know more about their dolphin
friends, and how they give each other names
get the scoop here